hello everybody my name is markiplier
and welcome to three weird games now
these games aren't weird because they
are so unbelievably out there they're
weird because they're methodology and
their utilization isn't necessarily what
you would find in normal games the first
game of which is actually controlled by
my singing so you'll see that soon but
before I get started I wanted to say
that I am leaving for Amsterdam in two
days this Wednesday I'm going to be
heading over to Amsterdam for our shows
on Saturday so if you haven't gotten a
ticket yet please check the link in the
description below for Amsterdam tickets
if you're anywhere in the near in the
air if you're anywhere in the area of
Amsterdam so check that out thank you
everybody for watching and enjoy okay so
this is one hand clapping so apparently
this game is controlled by your voice
you blue and sing away and then it does
something in the game I'm not a hundred
percent sure how accurate that's going
to be or how well I have to sing if I if
it requires any sort of accuracy I don't
know if it's gonna go too well no
nothing yet hello
all right I don't know what the hell
that was all about but that happened I'm
very happy about that
oh well huh Bella I can hear myself in
the game Oh
okay got that oh yeah okay I can see you
see that's why I'm fun with this one
okay all right so this is the game it's
pretty it's pretty fascinating this
guy's is gonna go off at all times just
because it's gonna it's good it's gonna
go off just because I'm talking all the
time anyway so it's like a little me
tinder like ba ba ba ba ba ba ba buk buk
buk buk buk buk buk okay oh wait
okay alright then I wish it was like you
know with Bugs Bunny like the orchestra
like it you raise it higher but yeah but
apparently nothing so I don't know what
they're doing about it
hmm well I don't know about this printer
Falls uh-oh
all right I don't know what I'm supposed
to do there but we got these moaning
crowd in the background and I don't know
what that's all about
so I can't get back no I'm stuck already
guys apparently I'm absolutely stuck
[Music]
yeah I don't know what I'm supposed to
do here higher pitch
[Applause]
as high as I can go I don't know what
more what it was doing something
[Music]
huh huh huh yeah okay all right that's
okay I think I need to recalibrate it
because it seems to me
okay that's low and now hopefully it'll
be not requirement oh hey how is it
oh that's horrifying some will worm
gecko going on over there
Oh
okay all right we got this we got it oh
yeah oh we're getting hmm
tough crowd out of here well you don't
like my singing path oh hello
oh I can stop now okay all right this is
a great vocal warmup game yeah this game
is cool yes I was I was curious to see
how exactly gonna be but it doesn't ow
my face
excuse you I just brush myself off it's
all good it's all good
oh where am i oh no was I ever see my
family again will I ever see them again
hmm I'm not singing anymore and I don't
know why I wish oh there it is la la la
I sing to keep me not lonely in the
Shuar I'm walking through thee oh my god
it's beautiful it's beautiful I oh hey
there
[Music]
that's what I heard did I not get it
tough crowd tough crowd you where is it
I don't know try singing within your
range oh okay let's try
[Music]
do you really want me to go back you
said the lowest comfortable note that I
could do and this [ __ ] hang on
[Music]
let's bow black blur bling bling
okay let me recalibrate again oh okay
there we go
got that on there yeah we're good okay
we got it
Oh what's this then this needs something
[Music]
Oh
[Applause]
it's not working
[Music]
Hey
Oh
[Applause]
[Music]
[Laughter]
it's not working ha hey hoo-hah la mi
mean home annoy me home annoy me hi me
know
oh that was the one that was the one oh
look it's shooting our music goop
everywhere
oh man the world's a beautiful place
what's this then
oh boy okay
[Music]
Oh
okay that's good enough for me I'll take
it Yahoo wahoo
okay I like giving myself a challenge I
believe I could actually glide up with
this hey it works all right cool
this is a good a nice yodel going on and
will actually make a good platform here
[Music]
they're good enough can I get over that
raw I don't think I can get over that
rock
maybe maybe come on Oh
ha ha all right say
okay seem good enough to me
[Music]
that's pretty cool wait is there a
secret path up there tell me that's a
secret path please please tell me please
tell me please tell me I want it to be
nothing more than a secret path
Oh
[Music]
okay let's try that No ah got that wrong
didn't work
thx up in here alright let's try this
please tell me that's a secret path
oh all right what are you
there we go got it nailed it I am the
best I am so good damn good thanks thank
you thank you
there's ah there's me at my best able to
showcase my talent properly and not just
uh through this [ __ ] who doesn't know
how to sing properly
[Music]
what am i doing
nail them nail it perfect I did exactly
what I wanted me to do come on brother
there we go god I think I can make this
jump
[Music]
li got it nailed it nailed it fine
am i blowing out everybody's ears my
absolutely blowing out everybody's ears
with this probably if I did Sound of
Music and some like perfect this is the
greatest game that ever existed this is
the best this is the best all right I'll
try to keep it a little farther away
I'll try to keep it a little farther
away but not much farther away just a
little bit just up spicy a little bit
oh nice got it nice I got it your ears
are bleeding but that's okay that's okay
I got this don't worry about a thing
just fell out of your chair might be
your belly hurts what is this funny to
you is my singing funny to you
[Music]
Oh
nice it's so cool this is such a unique
concept forget
Oh
so weird it's so weird
[Music]
it's so cool
that's so cool
Oh
[Music]
haha
haha it's so cool cuz you could hear
yourself it actually records your voice
in the game
uhh
Oh weird that's so weird
it's like this is actually trying to
teach you how to sing because it what
that was it was trying to help you find
intervals and then last one it's like
this game is teaching you how to sing it
this game is this games teaching you how
to save you that's what it's doing it's
like a rudimentary thing in it but it's
teaching you know saying it just so cool
Oh
got it / my voice and you get beautiful
music who also who's this guy or girl or
whatever la Wow we are literally gods
who can make things with our voices
[Music]
perfect nice very nice
penis man you can't just name everything
our penis
[Music]
nice I nailed it I nailed that I nailed
that hell yeah
[Music]
nice oh man this this is really cool
like as much as I'm joking around this
is this is legitimately cool they've
done a good job with this making some
official
[Music]
love
nice nice
says the guy okay listen I when's the
last time I named something a penis it
was you guys that name that Lake a penis
this is not a penis man you don't know
that's probably not good look out the
sun's looking at you you gonna blow off
the Sun
you better not blow up the Sun it's not
a penis beam you built the city
[Music]
a little a little dah-dah-dah-dah you
didn't know is that close enough
is that pretty good first my song I like
penis
[Music]
are they gonna record that or is that
like that like if can I have a do-over
on that song I don't think I really
[Music]
I wasn't really ready so if you could
like give me uh if I could get it if you
could let me have a do-over
[Music]
[Applause]
that's so cool that was really cool that
was really cool they did a great job
with this one this is but this is
something special this is something
special
like me like I'm not a great singer like
especially when I'm doing a let's play
but he if you were like trying to build
some sort of like ikono on a try like
it's it's the first game I've seen that
walks you through it so beautifully that
was so cool I was hoping that it was
gonna take the sample that I played and
like make it into the credit song like
just insert it somehow with some
algorithm and just make it into that but
that was so cool this one's called pet
the pup at the party how to play you are
at a house party you do not know anybody
but legend tells of a very good pop Oh
hiding somewhere in this house the clock
is ticking and you're running of course
I'm running it's a party where I don't
know any but I literally walked into
someone's house and I started sprinting
as fast as I can towards the pop Oh hmm
let's do this I'm gonna pet that puppy
I'm gonna pet that I'm gonna pet the
[ __ ] out of that puppy whoa hey um find
that pup hey how's it going
do you like Russian accent how about the
France you like you like a French accent
how about you dude you like it whatever
accent this is no I'm Squidward yeah
that's pretty much exactly that okay
hello hi excuse me
sorry sorry sorry sorry sorry
where's that puppy I heard pray tell
there was a puppy around here hey have
you seen a puppy sorry sorry papi papi I
heard that wait I heard a puppy I heard
it I heard it why does this bathroom
lead how big is this house I hear a
puppy I hear it Bobby
excuse me sorry how
oh wow all right where's that pop I
heard that pop
I heard that pop so it's a limited
amount of time I only get so much time
per pop that's pretty cool hip pop oh oh
oh I saw that arf I don't know if that
ARF is actually misleading me or if
that's a real arf arf arf or if again MA
Marco arfo Paulo this what are you doing
in here alone why are you smoking in the
bathroom who doesn't make any sense ah
goddamn it put me a long wrong way oh no
where's that Popo hello did that come
through here I can't remember
hello hello heard there was a pop oh
hello I can't hear it anymore
oh how do we get over there Papo Papo
oh there's pop Oh bed pop oh no pop Oh
pop Oh pop up pop oh oh oh that's a good
one that is it
gizmo gizmo oh this is sweet gizmo oh
right I think I heard it generally over
here pop oh oh hello pop Oh is there
another door in this bathroom
maybe hello sorry yeah god damn it oh no
oh no I meant if I went a fundamentally
wrong never mind I went the right way I
was miss hurting I'm gonna find that pop
I'm gonna find that book oh oh oh no
boat there no pop no pop there whoo I
heard that I heard that far away okay so
I get along ready to go I'm gonna find
this pup I'm gonna find this book hello
pop pop pop
what was that was it
what this is a dead end and what what is
this weird house
what kind of creepy party is this who
are you people
would you all come from and why am I
here and I don't know anybody there's so
many people in this place and I still
don't know anybody oh god damn it oh no
oh dear there may be a super just like
the first movies just looking around for
where the Orff's are coming from but
maybe the ARF's don't show up until you
get a certain distance to it because
that could be entirely bother
wait wait wait wait wait wait wait wait
whoa whoa whoa wait wait whoa Michi
how's it going Michi we're we're find
that pop okay pop that is there okay I'm
all right time before I'm able to find
this pop pop cheers me pardon me I need
to get a puppy I need to find one I'm
going to steal it I am literally here to
steal your dog whoever's house this is
yours I'm going to steal our shouting as
loud as I can I am going to steal the
dog that is at this party I hope that
someone doesn't stop me from stealing
the dog because that's my only objective
here
I am literally how where do I go I don't
know I've been here
hello oh boy oh no no no please
somebody help me find this dog it is
super important that I find there is no
dog there's no doors
there's no die it's a fundamental flaw
in the layout of this house there's
nothing I wish I could find hello
anybody okay alright this wait no secret
door secret door
you thought you could I for me pop
please I wish I could sprint I mean I'm
already running and obviously I don't
get a lot of exercise please pop please
no where by me now but please Oh
okay well that sounds pretty good
I talked to explore 69 I'm pretty good
but that's kind of a one and done unless
there's like there's 50 50 freaking to
papo's there are 50 oh my god
alright let's go again I wanna go again
I want to find this dog now that I know
what I'm doing now that I know instantly
go I saw that arf I saw that are well
this is a bad start
I saw the ARF it's on the other side
it's somewhere wrapped around excuse me
bar oh god I'm already off to a bad
start house yard hello hi hello nice
guitar hello hi oh you did here to do
yoga what are you doing here for oh
hello hello
nope nothing here hello
I heard that you can't run from me you
care
oh wait that sounded close that ah [ __ ]
I always go into a closet first just to
test myself oh boy oh boy this is always
gonna be a dead end
okay I don't know where that is I can't
tell I have no idea
hello anybody seen a pop okay here's the
ball for the pup where's the pup I don't
see a pup
I went the wrong way fundamentally
chairman uh-huh it's over there how do I
get over there though how do we that
doesn't make any sense how do I get is a
closet
there was no more doors I mean this just
goes over here this oh how did I miss
this
Oh oh my god dog please please talk
please help please help me get on my way
hello dog hello you look like a Dave oh
my god I heard that weird that pup Oh go
where's that Papa where's that papa
we're here we're yeah we're yeah pop up
Hey oh yeah wait over there
I saw it okay I'm a locked on target
where we're yet we're come on I gotta be
getting close
come on I know I'm close I know I'm
close yes Oh record time for dog Oh
record dog Oh record dog get yes oh yes
oh you look Linnell whoopee oh you're a
beautiful girl oh I heard that
okay I'm gonna find that pup this game
the best game this is best game this is
best game by the way the best game best
game ever made best game ever made
easily hundred percent best game okay I
see you I see you I see you I've got
three dogs in my arms and I can't put
anything down until I well [ __ ] um all
right well uh good uh dots right there
right there but how do I da it's right
there but how do I get there wait no
don't do this to me there's gotta be
like secret bathroom door it's right
there it's right on the other side of
this so how do I get over there how do I
get over there oh god damn it oh god
damn it
oh damn it oh no oh no oh no oh man
where can I get my hacks just a noclip
through the walls and be able to get
straight to the dog hello hi yes I know
I know I'm incredibly cool huh dog dog
dog dog dog oh my god that's a cute one
Cosmo Oh God why every time I go into a
closet immediately the first thing I go
to every single time is goddamn closet
okay right this way
hello hi hello hi I also like how I'm
running straight sprinting with my hand
jutting out in front of me like the most
threatening thing that I could do in a
roomful of other people just like
breathing heavily sprinting through
knocking over chairs with my hands
stretched out words you said so good
oh you sit so good you sit so good I'm
known for world-record pop pets by the
way I'm gonna get all of them in this
one
I'm never gonna stop hello hi hello
hello hi I don't care
hello I literally could not care less I
don't care you are human and therefore
irrelevant to this entire organization
hello ARF's yes wait wait we're close
wait wait right there right there right
there right there no no no how can you
talk with pizza in your mouth I don't
even understand hello hello here secret
girl where'd you go what the hell no I
was right through the odd did I go the
wrong way ah but it was totally worth it
on the pool table like Cleo like good
like a star way over there okay so I'm
guessing it's gonna be a wraparound from
the other side I have no reason to guess
that but it's gonna be over this way I
need to make a right eventually alright
here we go oh yeah okay there's a dog
bed dog oh oh this looks like chica
maybe maybe cute
definitely a hundred percent cute oh man
that was a good one oh man there's a
closet again hello hi how are you how
you doing good I don't care literally
don't talk to me just shut up everybody
literally just fall down a well I
literally couldn't care there's a dog
and I need to bet it I absolutely have
to bet this dog no matter what I do I
have to bet this dog excuse me pardon me
sorry pardon me get out of my way
alright hello hi nice [ __ ] I don't know
what kind of person lives in this
mansion but they're probably a stuck-up
[ __ ] but house close that was very
close where was that
where was that where God where was that
that was someplace nearby oh no oh oh no
oh no no no not like this not like this
was this a broken is that a door is that
supposed to be a door
no no not like this please
yes Maggie you look like Maggie oh my
god you're so cute
Florence I don't think it matters which
way you go because I believe there's
only like probably one generated path to
like the destination right it wouldn't
just it wouldn't just lead you around in
circles right am I going the right way
or the wrong way hello
Klaus it oh no I'm going the wrong way
oh god damn it oh no no please no not
like this no now when there's one more
bit I bet it's gonna be a really cute
one too I bet a secure this one that
I've ever seen hello hi oh no oh no this
way I don't know her for me or for more
time please oooh
nine eight oh my god oh my god please
please please yes yes yes yes oh that
was a good tartare those so worth it oh
so worth it I don't think I'm gonna get
another one well that's like it like
laser-focused into the exact right place
that I need to go to be able to get this
one pop mmm that's very close that's
really molder yes yes yes this is the
greatest day of my life this is the
greatest day of my life that's the
greatest day of my entire existence oh
man
whoa I heard that I don't know where get
out of my way Ned Jesus excuse me huh oh
yeah
secret door I love those secret bathroom
doors
[Music]
there it is ah through here yeah
was it in here no no no no no yeah yeah
yeah
where yeah it was here I heard it hey
Kelly hi Kelly
I got 11 I think I'm getting the record
on this one I think I'm doing real good
okay no secret door okay it's gonna be
down to the wire on this one I don't
know if I'm gonna make off [ __ ] I'm
definitely not gonna make it not now oh
no oh no the worst thing that could ever
happen to me is if I see it in sight and
I don't have enough time to get to it
that's gonna crush my entire soul I'm
never gonna forgive myself if that
happens oh no oh no oh no oh no oh no no
oh no oh no oh no wait I heard that no
please please I'm probably close eye I'm
probably definitely very close please
Ned get out the way
no no no not like this don't like the
damn you're dead damn you oh but that's
okay I listen to 20 episodes of my
favorite podcast hell yeah hell yeah
well I did it that was fun that's pretty
good don't pretty good don't pretty good
let me go back to I want to look at all
the all the various papo's there we go
there oh the good dog gallery oh that's
good oh we got some good ones oh we got
some good ones yeah oh we definitely got
some good ones
oh this BIOS for all of them Kelly
spaniel mix loves to spoon in the am
little spoon only ah oh my god
Italian grin just a fragile little dog
Oh draped in velvet oh my god dachshund
named after the iconic Florence Welsh
literal diva oh my god I bet she is
hashtag Dave of the wheat and smash that
like smash that like button smash it
Pembroke Welsh Corgi
here's cute may actually be the devil Oh
Papa hawawa good boy oh heck yeah most
definitely
Gracie Pembroke Welsh Corgi a bouncy
little bundle of love and kisses and
sports dog is mope Agarn loves cheese
does not love her Glen of amol terrier
part puppy mostly a scruffy gummy bear
oh maybe yellow lab eating sleeping
sitting like a proper lady maybe the
lady oh my god I'm gonna die she bit you
know spins in circles and bites her
fluffy tail when excited I do too husky
knows how to open doors mischievous
mastermind Oh me cheese so smart Michi
the mastermind Mulder dachshund trots
alongside you during walks wants to
believe I both don't know what that
means and absolutely know what that
means
wants to believe wants to believe
Penelope boxer loves squeaky tennis
balls hates flip-flops and tar black
laughs sweet soft boy misses his home
planet
okay that was pet the pup at the border
oh I'm glad I played it again and let it
play Diddy and I'm really glad I'm
really glad hello okay so this is
[Music]
holy [ __ ] my ears okay welcome to check
please
I don't like the way my hand is
undulating right now but this is a
physics-based dating simulator why is
that girl have a mustache why he got a
problem with girls with mustaches why
are you being judgemental over there
that's not very nice that's not very
nice at all oh and now now she doesn't
because she was self-conscious and she
shaved because you you could you were
judgy
you were judgey about it shame shame for
that judging someone on their appearance
is that shame that's a straight-up shame
can't believe you did that right
why doesn't it stay rotated wise wide
rotational only temporary okay all right
yeah I got it
how do i oh huh
excuse me can I rotate I can oh now it's
staying ah there we go
pour us some wine yeah soon as I figure
out what to do with this perfectly fine
hey don't you worry when it comes to
pour and wine I whoa
I know exactly okay
sorry this wines caught a little bad
it's curdled a bit all right
let's not let's not and say we did
excuse my Mademoiselle are you feeling a
little thirsty tonight you would relax
um excuse him where would you like uh
some one to quench your thirst and maybe
build the desire in your heart for
someone that such as me sorry you drop
that I can't help if your hands are not
as strong as mine well then it let me
help you out with that and there you go
so perfect so beautiful to us BLAP
blogger pour some one out for my homies
let's pour a little out for my homies
okay look I can't like what are you
offering me I poured us both wine just
cuz it wasn't in your hand okay this
date has gone horribly wrong can you uh
okay alright here just take this good
just grab it grab it with your firmly
grasp it that looks like it's in your
hand I don't know what you're talking
about
whoa what what what
okay all right we'll try this again ah
thank you I like you better this way
oh it is a little dark in here isn't it
well Mademoiselle
prepare to be swooned unlike any other
swooning experience you've ever seen but
lucky your moustache reminds me of my
own why can you feed three three
meatballs only three I will do for you
what I did four well cannot grant okay I
don't need a spoon we're so close we
just we always just fit right into each
other's gobs there you are would you
like another oh there you are
how about one more what was the problem
did that do it was that it was that it
hang on speed round speed round
apparently apparently I did something
wrong I'm sorry does my French accent
offend you Oh allow me to pour out the
wine what an excellent par would you
like some as well
no no no don't drop your goddamned glass
all right listen what the hell happened
to this oh listen it's a tall glass but
somebody has to feel it you know what
I'm saying am i late do you like my
accent it's much like me
well travelled I've been all over the
world I hope you can appreciate
something more wine Schism well how
about some straight in the gobble there
you are madam well so I'll okay let us
try this again I like your mustache
better but it not to be that way No
there's one I didn't pour enough wine in
the glass you're not supposed to fill a
glass with wine I don't know what I
don't know what school of thought you
went to for wine but it's it's supposed
to be in moderation there we are
three mint bulbs for you wanna ah well
that's weird why does it do that is it
because I'm not stabbing them with farc
I will get you you will see Oh
Mademoiselle you are uh throw some salt
over your shoulder for good luck there
you go beautiful just like you
okay well that we're done then I suppose
all right I'm gonna get this I'm a
spirit yeah we got oh yeah this is the
stuff ignore the fact that the bottle is
really pouring out there ah one
delicious meat the ball fur cannot to
move very fast with this here comes the
airplane here may I ask what's going
wrong this is [ __ ] alright fine
alright I take this seriously like
American hey how you doing the names
Marcus Marcus plier I've been known
around these parts as being the most
seductive man in existence it's your
great pleasure to be served wine today
oh yeah good thing I missed I didn't
really want to hit it you know my homies
definitely deserve some wine and so do
you can I call you a homey of mine I
hope I can there you go Mademoiselle to
us
trip to us
clink Clank clunk Clank I don't
understand you didn't put I have to have
to be her meatballs listen lady I filled
this up there you go
okay it has to be her well why did you
spill all your meatballs over on my side
if it was supposed to be your meatballs
that doesn't make any sense
yeah 1 2 & 3 here comes the airplane
milady why did she think I'm threatening
her I am doing my damnedest my damn best
do delious and it's not giving me the
thing that it should give me what the
hell this is this broken
it's broken you listen lady all right
I'm gonna be very I'm gonna take this
like so so sweetly and I'm gonna do it
in a Russian accent this time would you
like would you like vine no I don't know
that's not right I'm gonna go with it
would you like some vine would you like
vodka it's special red vodka very good
only for best dates I give to you yes
you like it good I pour look like blood
you remind me of good days all right I
get wine now you're done okay no drop
wine sorry had little bit before all
right wine back magically I pour more
for me I tried to moderate but it no
work that better you seduced yet is it
the accent it is probably okay all right
well would you sorry
wine bottle have so much alcohol wine -
run - bye bye
to me more like haha you have good time
alright do you know get cousin let's go
bowling answer I apologize I don't know
look our wine is doing what we're going
to do later you me me upside down you on
your side you know what I'm talking
about throw salt over shoulder for good
luck here comes the airplane
blue good luck have over there you
should be thankful you look like Aaron
Hanson right now
good lump head meal of game grumps I
love it you do good game grump do you
watch 10 minute power out this week it
good it really good alright start over
can't stop accent it's not good but you
know it's all I have may not have much
[Music]
all right
apparently that's good enough I like you
you know low maintenance
alright ready for airplane this time not
going to be very threatening and on
accent can seem a little little
threatening
I got a meatball for you you're going to
like this listen I come from not
threatening angle you like you like I'll
this is [ __ ] this is [ __ ] this
is [ __ ] this very clearly [ __ ]
is it is it really just like stab sorry
I'm sorry
listen you oh it is if you get the fork
too close she gets real mad now I'm just
a silly country boy but when I see a
mustache like that I can't help but fall
in love sploosh
now I don't know about ok art well
alright here comes the airplane
is that good enough for you look I'm
just gonna grab these mono alright
that's not good no touch is a good touch
I get it
I understand we'll see what happens next
time I guess one of these days I'm gonna
feed you but uh it's like 50 first dates
my favorite Adam Sandler movie and Adam
Sandler my favorite movie maker he is a
talented son of a [ __ ] there we go all
right that's enough for you um let's get
rid of that is that the olive oil I
don't know much about olive oil so I'm
just gonna toss that over there I'm
gonna get things out of the way so that
I can see you without no obstructed view
what if I just throw them your way is
that good oh that's gonna be that's
gonna be goddamn delightful ain't it
hope there we go okay apparently that's
not good enough father try the spoon try
using her fork that's it's just a bunch
not happening this it's just not doing
it and I don't know why I'm a romantic
top I'm read up on my Shakespeare what
light through yonder window breaks and
I'm gonna get that window fixed because
I broke it the other day but you your
slice of something special so I'm
thinking I'm gonna fix that for you I've
been putting it off for a while but I
ain't gonna put off for you now if you
put out for me I'm gonna put off for you
all right I'm just being straight up on
us you just got a trust you understand
she just got it you got it
good oh all right second I can't do it
that I can't do it this game doesn't
work it doesn't work it just doesn't
work
[Music]